THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 2200 OF
THE Þ STREET BUILDING. I ASK
THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COME TO THE HEARING
ROOM SO WE CAN BEGIN THE HEARING
. WE HAVE A SUBSTITUTE COMMITTEE
MEMBER THIS MORNING. SENATOR
WIENER WILL BE SITTING IN FOR
SENATOR ASHBY TODAY. SO WHEN HE
GETS HERE, WE'LL WELCOME HIM AND
I KNOW HE'LL DO A GREAT JOB. WE
HAVE 99 MEASURES ON TODAY'S
AGENDA, THREE OF WHICH ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR A DUE PASS MOTION.
THE REST OF OUR BILLS ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. WE WILL
EXTEND A COURTESY TO MEMBER
MEMBERS WITH Dð PASS ITEMS AND
ALLOW THEM TO PRESENT THEIR
BILLS OUT OF AGENDA ORDER AS
THEY SHOW UP. ALL MEMBERS WITH
SUSPENSE ITEMS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING HAVE
WAIVED PRESENTATION. WE WILL BE
TAKING TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC
ON EACH AND EVERY ITEM. HOWEVER,
EVEN IF THE AUTHOR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, I ALSO WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THAT SEVERAL BILLS THAT
ARE LISTED IN THE DAILY FILE FOR
TODAY'S HEARING HAVE BEEN
RESCHEDULED TO NEXT WEEK. THESE
ITEMS ARE SB 1354 BY SENATOR
WAHAB AND SB 1464 BY SENATOR
ASHBY. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS INDICATED THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE A FILE ON ANY OF THE
MEASURES BEFORE THE COMMITTEE,
AND THEIR REPRESENTATIVE WILL
NOT BE HERE TO TESTIFY. SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN, I WANT TO
REMIND ANY WITNESSES TO LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL. AND PLEASE
REFRAIN, REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY
POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND REPEATING
PRIOR TESTIMONY IN YOUR
COMMENTS. SO WE ARE GOING TO
START TODAY'S MEETING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, SO WE'LL
WE'LL GO STRAIGHT, ON IN TO OUR,
OUR TESTIMONY. AND SENATOR
DURAZZO IS HERE. WELCOME. WE'RE
EXCITED TO HAVE LIVE SENATORS
HERE. ROBOT AS OPPOSED TO I
PRODUCED. SO, SENATOR DURAZZO,
YOU'RE HERE ON SB 1350? YES
CORRECT, MADAM CHAIR. VERY GOOD.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, SB 1350
SIMPLY REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON POLICIES THE
STATE MAY ADOPT TO PROTECT
DOMESTIC WORKERS FROM WORK
RELATED INJURIES AND ILLNESSES,
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT, DESPITE,
CARING FOR WHAT WE HOLD MOST
DEAR, OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
HOMES, DOMESTIC WORKERS REMAIN
WITHOUT ANY HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS, AND THAT GOES FROM
THE DURING THE PANDEMIC, WHEN
DOMESTIC WORKERS WERE THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
CONTACTED COVID 19 OR CLIMATE
ACCELERATED DISASTERS, WHICH
MAGNIFY THE DANGERS THAT
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND DAY
LABORERS FACE ON A DAILY BASIS.
BEYOND THESE EXTREME DANGERS,
DOMESTIC WORKERS ALSO FACE RISK
OF INJURY AND ILLNESS IN THEIR
DAY TO DAY WORK RELATED TO
LIFTING CHEMICAL HANDLING AND
REPETITIVE STRAIN, AMONG OTHER
RISKS. SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
LAST YEAR OF MY PRIOR
LEGISLATION REMOVING THE
EXCLUSION OF PRIVATE PAY,
HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC SERVICE
EMPLOYEES FROM CALIFORNIA'S
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS, I HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH HIS OFFICE
REGARDING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF DOMESTIC WORKERS. I AM
HOPEFUL THAT THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WILL RESULT IN A MEANINGFUL STEP
FORWARD THIS YEAR. IN
ADDRESSING, ADDRESSING LÀ
INTIMATE HEALTH AND SAFETY RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH DOMESTIC WORK,
THE DIR INDICATES THAT IT WOULD
INCUR A ONE TIME COST OF $75,000
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL. AND WITH ME HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1350 IS CYNTHIA
GÓMEZ, DEPUTY DIRECTOR, STATE
POLICY AND ADVOCACY WITH CHIRLA.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
GÓMEZ. I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF STATE POLICY AND ADVOCACY
WITH THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. CHIRLA CHIRLA
IS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION AND A CURRENT MEMBER
OF THE COALITION STEERING
COMMITTEE. THE CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKERS COALITION
REPRESENTS NEARLY 300,000 HOUSE
CLEANERS, NANNIES, HOME CARE
WORKERS IN THE STATE AND HAS
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF WORKING
TO END THE EXCLUSION OF DOMESTIC
WORKERS FROM WORKPLACE SAFETY
STANDARDS. LIKE MANY OTHERS, ARE
PROTECTED BY DOMESTIC WORKERS,
ARE A KEY MEMBER OF THE CARE
ECONOMY, AND PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES TO MANY. IN RECENT
YEARS, DOMESTIC WORKERS HAVE
CONTINUED TO WORK THROUGH
CLIMATE DISASTERS, WILDFIRES,
FLOODS AND A GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND
ARE LARGELY COMPRISED OF WOMEN
AND IMMIGRANTS. A STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE UCLA LABOR
OCCUPATION OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROGRAM FOUND THAT DESPITE BEING
INJURED, 94% OF RESPONDENTS
REPORTED CONTINUING TO WORK
THROUGH THEIR INJURIES OUT OF
FEAR OF JOB LOSS OR FINANCIAL
LOSS. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT ALL
WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO SAFETY, A
SAFE WORK ENVIRONMENT. SB 1350,
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON POLICIES THAT THE
STATE MAY ADOPT TO PROTECT
DOMESTIC WORKERS. WE ESTIMATE
THAT SB 1350 WOULD BE A LOW COST
MEASURE, BUT ONE THAT HAS A
POTENTIAL TO BENEFIT THOUSANDS
OF WORKERS IN THE STATE. WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NEITHER
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A Dð PASS
RECOMMENDATION TODAY, ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS? ANY QUESTIONS?
OKAY. WE DO HAVE A QUORUM, SO IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ACTION, SO IF YOU
COULD CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE.
CABALLERO. HERE. CABALLERO HERE.
JONES. BECKER. BECKER. HERE
BRADFORD. SATO. HERE. SATO.
HERE. WAHAB WAHAB. HERE. WIENER
WE HAVE A QUORUM. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CONCLUDE? I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT, AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE A
MOTION? THERE IS A MOTION BY,
SENATOR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. CABALLERO A
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. BECKER A
BECKER I BRADFORD. CIERTO CIERTO
. NO. WAHAB. WAHAB I HAVE THREE
VOTES. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU MADAM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT UP IS SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN. YOU'RE
HERE ON SB 1449. THAT IS
CORRECT. AND THERE IS A Dð PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS ONE AS
WELL. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB 1449,
WHICH WOULD EXTEND AN EXISTING
EXEMPTION TO THE PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION ACT OF
2009 TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
REGULATORY RELIEF TO
SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES. IN 2010, THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ISSUED
NEW GUIDELINES REQUIRING
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO MAINTAIN A FORMAL PROCESS FOR
RECEIVING AND PROCESSING
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS. IN 2015,
THE STATE'S BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION INVITED
SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL TO ENTER
INTO A CONTRACT FOR THE PURPOSES
OF SATISFYING THAT REQUIREMENT.
RECENTLY, HOWEVER, THE BUREAU
NOTIFIED SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL
THAT THOSE CONTRACTS HAD BEEN
MADE IN ERROR AND THAT ABSENT
ACCREDITATION BY THE WESTERN
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES, BETTER KNOWN AS WOSC,
SOUTHWESTERN WOULD NEED TO
BECOME BUREAU LICENSED OR IT
WOULD FALL OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL LAW. MOREOVER, THE
STANDARD LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS
TO WHICH SOUTHWESTERN WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CONFORM, WHICH WERE
DEVELOPED TO REGULATE PRIVATE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND ARE
ADMIRABLY INTENDED TO PROTECT
STUDENTS INTERESTS, ARE IN MANY
CASES IN DIRECT CONFLICT WITH
THE STANDARDS AND PRACTICES OF A
DEDICATED NONPROFIT LAW SCHOOL,
SUCH AS SOUTHWESTERN. SB 1449
ADDRESSES THIS FLAW IN A
DELIBERATELY TAILORED FASHION BY
EXPLICITLY AUTHORIZING THE
BUREAU TO CONTRACT WITH THE
SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL PURSUANT
TO FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. I'M
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE TODAY. VERY GOOD IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1449?
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS GEORGE
MILLER, ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHWESTERN LAW AND SUPPORT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1449? SEEING
NONE, I STATED EARLIER, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOESN'T
HAVE FILES ON ANYTHING, SO WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HEAR FROM THEM, ANY
QUESTIONS OF SENATOR NEWMAN?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL ALLOW YOU TO
CONCLUDE. I RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY. VERY
GOOD. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS Dð PASS RECOMMENDATION SEN.
WAHAB MOVES THE BILL. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. BECKER AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. CIERTO WAHAB. WIENER.
THAT BILL HAS THREE VOTES. WE'LL
PUT IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU. ALRIGHTY SO WE'LL
START UP AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
LIST AND START WITH, SENATOR
WIENER'S SB 509, AS I, SENATOR
WIENER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
ON HIS BILL ON HIS BILLS. AND SO
WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB 509. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 509? FIVE Ã
905 I'M SORRY, DID I SAY ABOUT
509? WELL, IT'S CLOSE THIS,
THING, NO TESTIMONY. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 509905.
HOLY COW. I GUESS I NEED MORE
COFFEE, WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 960. WE'RE JUST
STARTING THE AGENDA. IT COULD BE
ROUGH, SB 960 BY SENATOR WIENER.
SENATOR WIENER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 960? ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 960? SEEING
NEITHER. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 960 WILL MOVE TO
THIS TO SUSPENSE. SB 1047 BY
SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR WIENER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. THOSE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MCCAULEY. ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
1047. SEEING NEITHER THIS BILL
OR FINISHING UP ON THIS ONE.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1047 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1227 BY SENATOR
WIENER. SENATOR WIENER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR THE SUSPENSE FILE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1227 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 906 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR SKINNER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 906?
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 906.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO SB 906. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. TAKING UP SB 1022 BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR SKINNER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1022?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1022?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE AS WELL, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1022 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1144
BY SENATOR SKINNER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. THOSE IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MCCAULEY, ON BEHALF OF THE LA
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD.
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1144? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE, CANDIDATE. SO SB 1144,
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 908 BY SENATOR
CORTESE. SENATOR CORTESE HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB 908?
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 908.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 908 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
915 BY SENATOR CORTESE, WHO
AGAIN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 915?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 915. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
915, WITHOUT OBJECTION, WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 999 BY
SENATOR CORTESE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 999? WELCOME HI,
TRENT MURPHY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 999? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE.
CANDIDATES WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
999 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB
1162 BY SENATOR CORTESE, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1162?
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO 1170
62? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1162 WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. SB 1298 BY
SENATOR CORTESE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1298? WELCOME.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
BRENDAN TUIG, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION, WHICH IS
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS FROM ALL 35 LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS. WE HAVE AN OPPOSED
POSITION. WE'VE SEEN THAT UNDER
THE CURRENT 100 MEGAWATT
EXEMPTION, THAT THE DEFAULT IS A
DIESEL. WHEN WE KNOW THERE ARE
CLEANER ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE.
SO WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THAT
UNDERLYING EXEMPTION. NOW THIS
INCREASES IT 50, SO ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS THAT THESE PROJECTS,
THESE LARGE PROJECTS SHOULD GO
THROUGH THE FULL NORMAL
CERTIFICATION PROCESS WHERE
THERE'S MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC INPUT AND MITIGATION. SO
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ALAN ABS REPRESENTING THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. WE HAVE AN OPPOSING
LESS AMENDED POSITION, TO BE
MORE PROTECTIVE OF COMMUNITIES
SUCH AS THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA,
WHICH IS THE ANALYSIS NOTES, HAS
HAD OVER 667MW OF DIESEL ENGINES
INSTALLED IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
UNDER THE EXEMPTION THAT 1298
PROPOSES TO EXPAND. SO OUR,
AMENDMENT THAT WE SUGGEST WOULD
BE TO ALLOW FOR THE ADDITIONAL
EXEMPTION TO THE CEC, BUT NOT
ALLOW THOSE EXEMPTIONS FOR
DIESEL ENGINE PROJECTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1298 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1299 BY
SENATOR CORTESE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1299? IN
OPPOSITION. TO 1299. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1299 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1373 BY SENATOR CORTESE, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1373?
IN OPPOSITION TO 1373? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1373 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 910 BY SENATOR UMBERG WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 910?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO SB
910. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 910 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
919 BY SENATOR UMBERG. SENATOR
UMBERG HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
ON THIS BILL. WOULD ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, RANDY POLLACK, ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
FRANCHISE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL, WE BELIEVE THAT
THE REGISTRATION FEES FOR THIRD
PARTY BROKERS WOULD OFFSET ANY
COSTS TO THE DEPARTMENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
, ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, THÀNH SB 919
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 939 BY
SENATOR UMBERG, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 939? ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 939 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 926 BY
SENATOR WAHAB, SENATOR WAHAB HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 926 WILL MOVE TO
THE SUSPENSE AS SB 983 BY
SENATOR WAHAB, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? SB 983
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL MOVE
SB 983 TO THE SUSPENSE SB 984 BY
SENATOR WAHAB, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
984 WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE SB
1355 BY SENATOR WAHAB. SHE HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL
AS WELL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
SB 1355 WILL MOVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB 934 BY SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB 934? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 934 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1253 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1253? WELCOME
YOU. IF YOU'LL COME UP TO THE
MIC Ó YOUR OPPOSITION. OKAY
SEEING NO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT,
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION. SB
1253 OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING.
I'M ELIZABETH ROSEMAY. I AM A
TWO TIME VIOLENT CRIME SURVIVOR.
I HAVE A CCW AND I ALSO HUNT,
I'M CONCERNED THAT THE SAFETY
CERTIFICATE WILL FUNCTION AS A
LICENSE TO POSSESS A FIREARM,
WHICH IS AN INSULT TO THE
CONSTITUTION. ALSO IT EXCLUDES
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM EVEN BEING
ABLE TO ACQUIRE THIS CERTIFICATE
. SO I ASK YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1253 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 942, SENATOR
BECKER, SENATOR BECKER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON HIS
BILLS. IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 942? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OF 942? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 942 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 993 BY
SENATOR BECKER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 993 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
1133 BY SENATOR BECKER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL, IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1133 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1254
BY SENATOR BECKER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1254 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1288 BY SENATOR
BECKER, WHO WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1288 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1307 BY
SENATOR BECKER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO SB 1307 WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB 1374 BY SENATOR BECKER, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? WELCOME.
HI. MEG SNYDER, AXIOM ADVISORS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
REWIRING AMERICA, SUNPOWER AND
PARALLAX IN SUPPORT OF 1374.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1374 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 943 BY
SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH SENATOR
OCHOA BORG HAS WAIVED.
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 943? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 943. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 943 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1040 BY
SENATOR OCHOA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1040? IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1040? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1040 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 970 BY
SENATOR ASHBY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON HER BILL. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS MCCAULEY, ON BEHALF
OF LA AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 970?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
OAN SB 970 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1180 BY SENATOR
ASHBY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? TÂM MURPHY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN ROOM 2200 THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1180 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1452 BY SENATOR ASHBY, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1452 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SENATOR GROVE,
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING ON SB 1270. YES,
MA'AM. THERE IS A DUE PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS. THANK
YOU MA'AM, VERY BRIEFLY, JUST A
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME PRESENT
TODAY. SB 1270, WHICH IS BROUGHT
TO ME BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE, THE CDFA MARKET
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH PROVIDES
SEVERAL SERVICES TO FARMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
PROJECTS MORE THAN, OR PROTECTS
MORE THAN $40 BILLION IN
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITIES. THE BRANCH ALSO IS
100% INDUSTRY FUNDED. HOWEVER,
FEES HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED IN
OVER TEN YEARS. WHEN IT WAS
BROUGHT TO ME BY CDFA, I CHECKED
WITH OUR LOCAL FARMERS. THEY
SUPPORT THIS THIS BRANCH OF THE
AGENCY, AGAIN, NO COST THAT WE
CAN DETERMINE BASED ON STATE
RESOURCES BECAUSE IT'S 100%
INDUSTRY FUNDED. NOT SURE IT'S
WHY IN APPROPRIATIONS, BUT WE'RE
HERE TO SAY WE APPRECIATE THE DO
PASS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. VERY GOOD. WE DO NOT
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO SPEAK TODAY, SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THOSE IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1270? ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NEITHER,
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE? IF NOT, I'LL
ENTERTAIN A. I'LL ALLOW YOU TO
FINISH. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. VERY GOOD. IS THERE A
MOTION? OKAY WE HAVE. WE HAVE A
MOTION. OKAY. WE DO. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. CABALLERO
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. JONES.
BECKER AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO
WAHAB. WIENER WE HAVE THREE
VOTES ON THAT. WE'LL PUT IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
APPRECIATE IT. THERE'S ANOTHER
TWO BILLS OR DO YOU WANT TO.
LET'S JUST WAIT FOR SENATOR Tê
FOR THE BILL. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO, SB 1453. THAT'S
OKAY. YEAH, YEAH. SO LET'S,
LET'S, LET'S DO THE UNUSUAL
BECAUSE SENATOR WAHAB IS BEGGING
ME TO DO IT, WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO, SENATOR GROVE'S SB 1270
AND, AND, CALL THE ROLL AGAIN. I
BEG, DO YOU WANT TO LIFT THE
CALL ON ALL THREE BILLS? YEAH SO
WE'RE STARTING WITH SB 1270.
OKAY THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CHAIR VOTING.
AYE. JONES. CIERTO WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER SO THAT, NOW HAS
FOUR VOTES WILL PUT IT BACK ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
WE'LL GO BACK AND, WE HAVE TWO
OTHER BILLS THAT WE PUT ON CALL,
WITH Dð PASS RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE FIRST IS SB 1350 BY SENATOR
DURAZO, AND WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON THAT. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CHAIR VOTING AYE. JONES
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE WIENER.
THAT BILL IS 4 TO 1, AND WE'LL
PUT IT BACK ON CALL AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP SB 1449
BY SENATOR NEWMAN. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. CHAIR
VOTING AYE JONES. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO WIENER
THAT BILL HAS FOUR VOTES AND
WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT BACK ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
THOSE ARE THE ONLY BILLS THAT
HAVE THE DO PASS RECOMMEND
MOTION. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO SB 1453 BY SENATOR ASHBY. AND
SENATOR ASHBY HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1453? ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1453 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE. SB 1454 BY
SENATOR ASHBY. SENATOR ASHBY HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1454? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1454. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1454 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1455 BY
SENATOR ASHBY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE DESIRE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? SB 1455 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO SB
1455 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
1456 BY SENATOR ASHBY. SENATOR
ASHBY HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1456 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MOVING ON TO
SB 1502 BY SENATOR ASHBY, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1502?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF SB 1502?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1502 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 977 BY SENATOR
LAIRD WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
, SB 977 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
SB 1064 BY SENATOR LAIRD, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE
HERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE HERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1064? THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1064 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 997 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
SENATOR PORTANTINO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 997? CHAD MURPHY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES, WE'RE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. TO
997? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 997 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE SB 1116 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MCCAULEY, ON BEHALF OF SHERM,
THE SOCIETY FOR HUMAN RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT AND THE LOS ANGELES
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO 1116.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MARLON
LARA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1116 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1160 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1160?
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY? I ASKED IT IN
SUPPORT. OPPOSITION LOST MY
TRAIN OF THOUGHT. ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO 1160? THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1160 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 998 BY
SENATOR RUBIO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 998? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 998. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT ANY OBJECTION, SB 998
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1230
BY SENATOR RUBIO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? SB 1230 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1230 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1419 BY
SENATOR RUBIO. SENATOR RUBIO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1419 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1008 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR
BRADFORD HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
. WE THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND, IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1008 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1059 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1059 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1403 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? WELCOME YES. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS DARLENE
CROMARTIE, A MEMBER OF KGEC IN
THE BAY AREA. I AM IN TOTAL
SUPPORT OF SB 1403. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS KIM MIMS
WITH COALITION FOR A JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
REDRESS COALITION OF CALIFORNIA,
SACRAMENTO BRANCH AND AMEND THE
MASS MEDIA GROUP IN FULL SUPPORT
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 1403? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1403 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1021 BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
SENATOR ARCHULETA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1021? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1021 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1262 BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT ANY, WITHOUT ANY
OBJECTION, SB 1262, MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1315 BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. HE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL AS
WELL. IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1315, WITHOUT OBJECTION, WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1388 BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1388 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1033 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1033? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1033 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1492 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE? AND SENATOR
MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION? IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 1492? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1492. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1492 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. OH. I'M SORRY.
DIDN'T SEE YOU MOVE. HI, I'M MEG
SNYDER ON BEHALF OF PRIME HOME
HEALTH AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I APPRECIATE THAT ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO 1492?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1492 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1042 BY SENATOR
ROTH. SENATOR ROTH HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1042. HOW
ABOUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
1042? THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. CANDIDATE SO SB 1042.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1289 BY SENATOR
ROTH, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1289 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1511. BY
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. IT'S GOING
TO SAY HEATH, IS THERE ANYONE
IN. AND OBVIOUSLY THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IS NOT HERE. SO IS
THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1511?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A CANDIDATE FOR THE SUSPENSE
FILE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
1511 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
1053 BY SENATOR BLAKESLEE.
SENATOR BLAKE'S FEAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1053 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1061
BY SENATOR LIMON. SENATOR LIMON
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING. SAVANNAH JORGENSEN WITH
THE LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC
POLICY, CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE. SO SB
1061 WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. SB 1101 BY SENATOR LIMON.
SENATOR LIMON HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 1101 IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO SB 1101 WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1115 BY SENATOR LIMON, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF 1115 TÍNH? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1115 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1472 BY SENATOR LIMON. SHE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1472 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1088 BY
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL. SENATOR
ALVARADO GIL HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1088? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1088 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1089 BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1089? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 1089 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1446 BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY? SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1446? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1446 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1090 BY SENATOR DURAZZO,
SENATOR DURAZZO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? SAVANNAH
JORGENSEN WITH THE LUTHERAN
OFFICE OF PUBLIC POLICY,
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1090? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1090
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB 1107 AGAIN BY SENATOR
DURAZZO WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1107? THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1107 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE. SB 1375 BY
SENATOR DURAZZO. IS THERE ANYONE
? SENATOR DURAZZO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SAVANNAH JORGENSEN WITH THE
LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC
POLICY, CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1375 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1447 BY
SENATOR DURAZZO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1447?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 1447. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1447
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1111
BY SENATOR. MEN. SENATOR. MEN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1111?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. SB 1111 IS THE
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, OAN SB 1111
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1402
BY SENATOR MINH. SENATOR MINH
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1402?
HOW ABOUT ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
1402 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1118 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY? SENATOR
EGGMAN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
1118? HOW ABOUT ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1118 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1491 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN IS THERE. SENATOR EGGMAN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF 1491?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 1491. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1491, WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'LL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB 1123 BY MÐI I HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1123? HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION TO 1123? THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1123 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1432 BY
MYSELF. SENATOR CABALLERO,
ANYONE HERE? AND I'VE WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
THIS TWO IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB 1432 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE 1138 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN
HESITATION. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 1138? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT ANY OBJECTION, SB 1138
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1218
BY SENATOR NEWMAN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BUT IN
OPPOSITION? THIS IS A SUSPENSE.
FILE CANDIDATES FOR SB 1218 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1362 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANY ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES FOR SB
1362. WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'LL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1217 BY SENATOR GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? KENNY LAM FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE, ON
BEHALF OF COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1217? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1217 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE SB 1382 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. HE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 1382? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1382 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1482 BY
SENATOR GLAZER. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO. HE HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL
AS WELL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE AS WELL. SO SB
1482 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1233 BY
SENATOR WILK. SENATOR WILK HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1233?
HOW ABOUT ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1233? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1233 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE SB 1359 BY SENATOR
WILK, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYBODY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THÀNH THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1359 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1234 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. SENATOR ALLEN HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1234?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE.
CANDIDATES ARE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 1234 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1339 BY SENATOR
ALLEN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1339 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB
1436 BY SENATOR ALLEN, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 1436, BUT ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1436. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE. CANDIDATES ARE
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1436 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1267 BY SENATOR DOLLY.
SENATOR DOLLY HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1267? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO 1267?
THIS FILE IS A SUSPENSE FILE.
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
, SP 1267 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
SB 1423 BY SENATOR DOLLY, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1423?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION TO 1423?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE.
CANDIDATES ARE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 1423 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1400
BY SENATOR STERN, SENATOR STERN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1400? IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1400? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE. CANDIDATES
ARE WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1400
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WANT TO
CALL ANY OF THE MEMBERS? FROM A
PROPS THAT WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ADD ON, WE'RE GOING TO BE
LIFTING THE CALL ON THE THREE Dð
PASS BILLS, WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THEM DOWN HERE SO
THAT THEIR VOTE CAN BE RECORDED?
WE'RE ALMOST DONE. SB 1430 BY
SENATOR NILO. SENATOR NILO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1413?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 13 1413.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SB 1413 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1459
BY SENATOR NGUYEN, SENATOR
NGUYEN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1459 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. ALL RIGHTY. SO
LET'S GO BACK. AND.
GOOD. PERFECT. YEAH. HE'S GOT AN
OFFICER THERE. WENT DOWN. SO.
OKAY OKAY. SO WHERE AM I? K¾T
VIÆT. YEAH.
OKAY. WE'RE. WE'RE GOING TO
FINISH UP THE COMMITTEE AND LIFT
THE CALLS. AND WE'LL START WITH
SB 1350 BY SENATOR DURAZZO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. JONES. NO
JONES. NO. WIENER. Ã. WIENER
AYE. 5 TO 2. THAT THAT BILL IS
OUT. 5 TO 2. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR NEWMAN. SB 1449, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. JONES, THIS IS
NEWMAN. YES JONES. AYE. SATO
WIENER. WIENER. AYE 6 TO 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 6 TO 0. AND THEN SB
1270 BY SENATOR GROVE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CHAIR VOTING AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. SATO WIENER. WIENER.
AYE 6 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. 6
TO 0. THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA
FOR TODAY. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING, THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU ALL